EXPLOSIONS IN UKRAINE, WE ARE
SHOWING YOU NEW VIDEO.
LUCAS IS LIVE IN THAT COUNTRY
NOW WHERE IT IS AFTER 2.
.
20 IN THE MORNING.
THERE ARE RUSSIAN WAR SHIPS
CARRYING RUSSIAN MARINES HEADED
ODESSA THE THIRD LARGEST CITY
THEY ARE PREPARING FOR AN ARC
ASSAULT ON THURSDAY.
>> RUSSIA FIRED 450 MISSILES IN
UKRAINE.
THIS IS THE NATIONAL UNIVERSITY
AND POLICE DEPARTMENT ON FIRE.
UKRAINE'S SECOND LARGEST CITY
THE SIZE OF DALLAS.
>> AIR BASE A DRAMATIC VIDEO
WHAT THE RUSSIANS UNLEASHED THE
SITUATION LOOKING LIKE SYRIA.
NOT THE IMPROVED AND MODERNIZAD
RUSSIAN MILITARY MOSCOW WAS
BOASTING ABOUT.
BRITISH SAY 5 UKRAINIAN CITIES
ARE SURROUNDD AND THE RUSSIAN
DEFENSE SAID 498 RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS KILLED 1500